The kick it off.
We have a wonderful guest on Zoom.
She's the founder and CEO of Uoma Beauty,
and the bold leader of Make It Black
and Pull Up For Change.
Which are two initiatives in beauty that changed the game.
She is friend of the show, Sharon Chuter.
Hi.
Hi Drew.
Hi Sharon.
All right, well, we're going to start the news
with what people are freaking out about.
It's a hot new filter on Instagram
and it's called pillow face.
And Yahoo Life Reports said it transforms your face
to show you what you would look like
if you went straight to filler town
and went a little bananas.
All right.
Take a look at these pics.
Actress, Ashley Benson, posted one.
Sophie Turner went to this,
and Lily Collins also joined in on the fun.
And the filter was started for fun,
but it's become a very strong visual way
of talking about extremes, injectables, plastic surgery.
Ross and I took it for a spin.
Yeah, I'm opposed to this,
but I secretly kind of want to look like this.
And this is what I'd look like
if I really went crazy town.
(laughter)
Oh my god.
I know, it was sort of a joke,
and then I looked at it I'm like, "Well,
I hate 80% of it, but..."
Ross, I would tackle you.
Although it's a funny app,
it does say something of what people are doing.
I did it.
You did it too?
My picture.
Oh Drew.
By the way, I look like my mother
and Jocelyn Wildenstein's love child.
Literally, it's my mom and the cat lady had a baby.
This is so not okay.
Oh my God, I want you to show up like that one day.
Sharon, what do you think?
Because, I love your opinion on, well,
pretty much everything.
Yeah, look, I like everybody to their own thing, right?
Beauty is in the eyes of the beholder.
But, look, I'm fortunate enough
that I've always had giant lips,
so I don't relate to the problem.
Sometimes I'm like, I can sit this one out.
It's true.
You've got the lips, the bone structure,
you've got what everybody's trying to get.
Lucky now, I used to get bullied for it.
I used to get called a frog,
because back then it wasn't trendy.
So I was just this person walking around
with all of this and all of that,
and so now I'm (mumbles) for it.
I'm actually now just sitting there laughing,
going like, "Yay, now it's trendy."
That's amazing, you're so lucky, right?
What you're insecure of in yourself becomes the trend,
one day I have double chins is the whole thing.
And everyone's getting this, right?
We all do.
Injections down here.
Sharon, I think you've been on trend
then, now and forever.
And Sharon, you have also got the next story.
Oh, I'm telling you though,
so this one, I'm once again, the bearer of bad news.
So Huffington Post just reported
that whatever makeup you've bought pre-pandemic.
You've got to chuck it, you have to throw it out.
So now I'm going to tell you that
I'm verifying that that's actually true.
So let me tell you something Drew
that most of you don't know.
On your makeup products there is always a label
that looks like a container that's half open
with a number on it.
It is called period after opening,
for most lip products is between eight to 12 months.
For most eye products is about six months.
A lot of consumers don't pay attention
to that tiny little detail.
But for your own sanity,
for your own hygiene you've got to pay attention to that
and you got to chuck it.
People don't know this,
but please go into your makeup cabinet
and almost everything pre-pandemic
is gonna be ready to be thrown out.
You've got to chuck them out after a while,
just giving you that.
It's true, you cannot buy in bulk
and you have to refresh when it comes to makeup.
I'm really glad you brought this into light,
because I think a lot of people
don't want to waste their money.
And then they're not necessarily being hygienic,
and it's safer to start fresh.
Sharon, this story really spoke to me
because you were just highlighted
in a Vogue business piece.
About the fashion industry can learn from
the all-purposeful activism in the beauty industry.
And you are one of my favorite leaders in this,
you're changing the beauty industry
with Pull Up For Change and Make It Black.
Do you think that the fashion industry
can step up in certain ways?
Are you interested in calling them out?
They're watching what you're doing,
what can they do?
Well, I think they really need to understand
the role that they play.
And it's really been, for me, really disheartening
seeing how the industry has tried to sit this out.
And it's because it's a real exclusive industry,
it's an industry that is not used
to listening to its consumers.
And for now it's an inconvenience
because they know you still got to buy clothes, right?
How are you going to boycott that, right?
I am very hopeful that we'll see more action
because right now, fashion as an industry
hasn't moved in the way beauty,
which is a very democratic industry.
An industry that right now
is 100% controlled by the consumer
has actually moved to the place.
So I want to see some fashion brands
really leading the charge, and making meaningful change,
not only in diversity, but in sustainability too.
Sharon, when you...
Really tell people
what they need to do and when they need to do it,
they do leap into action.
You have such strength, intelligence, and conviction.
I look forward to seeing your challenging of this industry.
Ross.
That was so well said.
I never thought about it like that,
the differences between the beauty industry
and the fashion industry.
Consumer-driven.
Exactly.
And also, in addition to that, you recently launched
a collaboration with Coming To America,
that's all about celebrating black beauty.
Can you tell us about that?
Look how gorgeous that is.
I know, I'm trying not to fan girl,
even right now I'm still in that moment.
For me, Coming To America was a huge part of my childhood.
This was the first time for me,
not only being black but being African,
we saw ourselves on the big screen looking elevated
and not beat.
It wasn't a Live Aid, a lot of poverty kind of brigade,
and so we went in on this collection.
I was under pressure
to represent my entire continent properly.
And so for me, I quite literally snapped,
this is the most personal collection I've ever made.
In terms of the texture, the formulas,
and just to look at that.
(cheering)
Oh my god.
We do not come here to play.
And through this, I highlight stories of my culture.
And through this collection, I'm taking all of my consumers
to the real African royalty and real royal heritage.
So I'm really excited about this one.
You should be, this is beautiful.
So good.
Yeah, it's the color and energy of the film
right here in a palette.
Beautiful job.
Yes, thank you.
Yay.
Before we go, it's beauty week on the show,
and I was wondering if you could share one beauty tool,
tip, hack, anything you're obsessed with right now
that we need to know about.
Oh my God.
Okay, I have a lot,
but I'm going to keep it short for you guys.
We're still in a Zoom world,
I know we're still trying to come out here.
But I will tell everybody
just having a mascara on the top and bottom lid.
Everybody forgets the bottom, put it on the bottom,
and you will get a full.
Your eyes will just instantly.
Well, Sharon, we will be putting it
on the bottom, on the top.
And you are just our hero.
We love you.
Thank you so much for joining us again today
for the umpteenth time,
and let's do many more.